mais américaine a donc reconnu que sa
dernière frappe sur kaboul était une
erreur un missile tiré le 29 août
dernier qui avait pour cible à des
combattants du groupe etat islamique
une erreur qui a coûté la vie à dix
civils dont des enfants selon le général
à kenneth mackenzie plus de précisions à
washington avec thomas bonne et que l'on
rejoint tout de suite
thomas bon soir donc vous avez plus
d'informations sur ces déclarations
et bien devant la presse vous l'avez dit
ce général kenneth mckenzie qui était le
chef des forces américaines en
afghanistan jusqu'au retrait des troupes
le 31 août dernier l'a donc reconnu
devant la presse que la dernière frappe
américaine dans le pays qui a été menée
le 29 août dernier et elle est bel et
bien une erreur notre enquête comme dit
il conclut désormais que cette frappe
était une erreur tragique il affirme
également qu'il assume la pleine
responsabilité
j'offre mes sincères condoléances à la
famille et aux amis de ceux qui ont été
tués on rappelle que dix civils ont
perdu la vie lors de cette frappe
aérienne dont sept enfants on a
également entendu il ya quelques
instants le ministre américain de la
défense qui a présenté ses excuses alors
il faut rappeler qu'il ya une semaine
c'est un article du new york times qui
faisait part de révélations justement
sur cette frappe aérienne s'appuyant sur
des documents remis par la famille d'une
victime puis d'autres médias avaient
embrayé et à chaque fois les autorités
américaines répéter qu'elle avait bel et
bien atteint une cible de l'état
islamique khorassan notamment suite à
des menaces après l'attentât qui a causé
la mort de 13 soldats américains près de
l'aéroport de kaboul les autorités
américaines qui ont donc fini par
reconnaître leurs erreurs aujourd'hui il
faut préciser que lors de cette
allocution face à la presse le général
mckenzie a également affirmé qu'aucune
action disciplinaire ne sera engagée
contre quel contre quiconque au sein des
forces armées américaines
merci beaucoup thomas bonnet pour toutes
ces précisions